so do you think it's excessive that he's
being charged uh for making a terrorist
no he should be [ __ ] charged for
being a 51 year old loser he's got he's
got that's a bigger charge he's gonna be
in jail 60 days for this no no two
months too much okay no no no no that's
60 days
[Laughter]
[Music]
so this dude right he's live streaming
on his phone he's dressed like the Joker
he's got the whole Blue Blood oh damn oh
he probably gets a lot of push-powers
how quickly that you were able to figure
that out
[Laughter]
cam boy he is that's slope intercept
form so he goes he's doing his thing
outside of like a little restaurant he's
just like this weirdo he's he's way he's
doing it at a restaurant
and he's like talking to his thing he's
as the Joker and he says how serious or
whatever like that yeah and then he's
like talking about getting a drink and
then he says well I I can't be
inebriated when I'm planning on you know
killing a bunch of people uh oh my God
was he really gonna do anything that's
his defense that he was just playing a
character so what do you think should he
be in trouble or not yes he should be in
trouble yeah
I think they should give him a slap on
the wrist say hey learn your lesson
don't say his dumb [ __ ] okay no that's
like saying bomb at the airport you know
you ain't supposed to say that's more
likely but then this is like if he's
saying it in a tone where he's like
joking and like sarcastic let's change
your opinion this this dude is 51. oh
yeah no so for me I'm with I'm with
Anthony because I think the biggest
difference between actually playing a
character and letting the world know
you're playing a character is getting a
film permit
if you got a film permit for this
sidewalk right because that's true
five dudes all like tactical to [ __ ] up
with ARs on the sidewalk but there's
film permits everywhere you're like oh
they're filming something this is fake
you're right five dudes oh no we're just
practicing for Halloween later it's like
bro dude how the [ __ ] am I supposed to
know I think it's also the setting too
he said out in public in a restaurant if
he was at like a Comic Con or something
saying all this [ __ ] probably you know
or in his basement time and place yeah
exactly but even then to be like I'm
gonna kill everyone it's like well
that's a that's a trigger word that's
you shouldn't be and then it's like live
stream it's not like Comic-Con context
somebody will take something that we
might have said but these are like
pre-recorded the environment you know
that this is like a talk show you say
stuff there's other people in the room
that are like hahaha you know you should
go to jail for the bad like
you know acting
Joker would never say I'm gonna kill a
lot of people you're right like he would
Nest you on the nose he's way more way
more way than that based off of that
script it's already a bad job and you
should go to jail for that so when he
says no let's play a character they're
like no you were it that sucked ass yeah
they bring in somebody from DC they're
like uh Joker doesn't actually say those
things so do you think it's excessive
that he's being charged uh for making a
terrorist no he should be [ __ ]
charged for being a 51 year old loser
he's gone he's got that's a bigger
charge he's gonna be in jail 60 days for
this no no two months too much okay no
no no no that's 60 days
and I think I like to count in months
got you I also believe that if you get a
terrorist threat as a charge you would
now on the no-fly list by default right
oh [ __ ] no he can't ride Frontier no
more
yeah
like I mean I think he also wasn't armed
when they when they got it does he have
any priors or anything like that that's
a great question because uh he has
previously served
no way is this really him I'm sorry uh
he's previously served more than 20
years in both federal and state prison
ah poor guy
um yeah this isn't a slap on the wrist
this is a get them off the street how
does this guy look
like the Joker Guantanamo Bay or
something it looks like that
dude that was crazy man that fool looks
nice he was really good to do it that
feels like he eats people if I'm reading
this correctly then it says during the
1980s he tried to rob a credit union to
fund his addiction to crack cocaine dude
he probably actually really wanted to be
that's my character I just Rob Base so
here's another thing that might change
your minds about it uh they took it very
seriously because you guys remember the
Batman screening yeah Oh I thought
you're gonna talk about the Japanese
Joker that like was murdering people on
the train that happened too oh [ __ ]
that's right yeah well I forgot about
that yeah the Batman theater a guy named
James Holmes uh comes into the theater
dressed as Joker and he kills 12 people
oh that was a long time ago I think um
2012. the opening right yes yes
like imagine just having a nice dinner
with your girl right you're at the Buca
di Beppo
one of the best Italian restaurants of
America Red Robin the gem of Nick's
neighborhood yeah yeah you're you're
eating a meatball marinara right just
you're doing a [ __ ] lady in the Trap
remake you get the [ __ ] Noodle and
you're about to kiss and then you look
over and this [ __ ] is sitting
right there eating alone doing a mukbang
live stream talking about oh God I call
the cops man he's ruining my [ __ ]
moment right now yeah
we're eating fancy tonight so he could
just be like a general nuisance to
society and a lot of a lot of murders
have they've been going live lately so
he really just we've really been doing
all the the moves he checked all the
boxes yeah he's checking all the boxes
it's been the most recent Riddler and
the most recent Batman movie will be
live streaming and stuff like it's like
a theme because of the technology it's
just part of the culture and then when
you look at the like ingredients to his
life and you're like all right do you
have any priors like oh yeah he's been
in the system for 20 years you're like
um that's not an act bro like you off
the chain right I don't like that he
he's like what's the big deal I was just
joking yeah that's what he said he goes
everybody knew that it was a joke and
had no intentions of following through
with a threat well everybody knew it was
everybody a joker killed somebody in the
theaters exhibit B a joke or kill
somebody I mean if he ends up getting
yeah if he ends up getting flagged he
actually had a viewer did he think it
was a good idea to even do that like is
he ins is that like his favorite
characters so he said that he live
streams to bring awareness to drug
addiction oh bro to keep doing it is
that what he's he's awareness that I
have a big Flagship guy like you don't
want to be like me she just dresses the
Joker tell him about he's gonna kill
people and he's like I've been three
years sober like that's not really the
good I don't
know I mean he's not winning awards for
it but yeah this is where he [ __ ] up
he chose the wrong character the mascot
for anti-drugs what's the better one
partner Barney
for anti-drunk Barney either one
Barney's Barbie's good too because like
you don't okay so if this guy was Barney
right yeah or Teletubby or something
Barney look they look like they were
invented you don't think that's too
young for anti-drug awareness well the
same generation that grew up on Barney
will know the reference gen Z is not
gonna know really right but us if we're
crack addicts at this age he's like 51.
I see I see and we'll be watching and
he'll be like hey guys
about killing people and then like when
you're at Buca di Beppo Barney's in
there and then we're back there this
it's not working nobody's gonna care I'm
not gonna [ __ ] I'm just like look at
this guy making a joke about killing
everybody in a Barney outfit it's more
lighthearted yeah it's way it's the
character like it's it's it's like your
Joker a person did pretend to be Joker
to kill people before true so it's like
Barney doesn't have priors no it's all
in the character Choice Sonic the
Hedgehog would have been cool true
Pikachu would have been cool yeah he
chose a villain he did and then made
villainous remarks and then it was like
I was joking about my villainy yeah he
used a lot of villain words right
villainous thank you you know if he do
it villain if he was saying I like that
thank you
Sailor Moon okay I think so I think so
if people Sailor Moon his testicles were
out and he's talking about I'm a you
know
all the cops uh-uh I'm gonna trust that
one even less trust if he was Sailor
Moon versus Barney I just yeah it's a
little really there's quite the slope
there you know what I mean okay well I'm
just I'm just saying like there's Tommy
Pickles Rugrats yeah a lot of other
characters he could have jumped up in a
big diaper he's older too it would have
made a little sense you know what I find
very sad is that this guy didn't so he
didn't actually do it right he didn't
have any weapons on him he really didn't
do anything more than badly play a
character and make threats that could be
taken out of context he pled guilty to
the charges
in hope in hopes of they would just drop
them but he still ends up getting
terroristic threat charged 60 days in
jail
oh yeah
that's actually terrorizing it's a funny
comparison whoa where what state where
it's it's all about the timing though
right there's like a sensitivity to like
digitized and Manifesto styled mass
shootings and killings of those types
right well maybe because Missouri
actually catches and puts people in jail
and [ __ ] yeah they must just do better
that's really good yeah but he's in jail
watching the McDonald's terrorist and
he's like what the [ __ ]
he's all damn New York has a good dude
just before we like cut like I was
watching my friend's story and she was
taking you know pictures of like cops on
the street that she's on right now and
apparently there was a guy with a gun
and a rifle that's like threatened to
shoot whatever they handcuffed the guy
and then let him go so they let similar
Stars right then and there he actually
had a [ __ ] gun oh they disarmed him
whatever let him go damn so stay tuned
for the next week episode
crimes don't get punished in L.A man
what can you imagine like you take a
guy's gun away
like all right
here you go here hold it
this is how you shoot someone if you
really want to shoot
now go now go now see you later that's
definitely
the crabs are gonna be less punished in
L.A but they're more critical of acting
in Missouri
[Music]